notre édition spéciale continue depuis
les allées de ce 105e congrès des Mair
de France on va parler d'urgence
environnementale les élus sont là aussi
en en première ligne en cas de
catastrophe climatique mais aussi pour
respecter les règlement mise en place
pour limiter ce ce réchauffement pour
restaurer la biodiversité parmi eux le
zan zéro artificialisation net pour
certains Mair ça tourne au casse-etête
exemple dans la ville de fin on est en
nîle etven Flora sauvage
l'acronyme suscite toutes les
appréhensions des élus locaux zan pour
zéro artificialisation nette l'objectif
réduire progressivement l'emprise au sol
des nouvelles constructions d'ici à 2050
la Bretagne va accueillir 400000
nouveaux habitants à l'horizon 2050 un
véritable casse-tête pour les maires à
fince en île et Villaines le premier
IDIL appréhende l'application de la
loisane face à l'accueil des nouveaux
arrivants aujourd'hui on a plus de
terrain à vendre sauf à diviser des
parcelles la difficulté c'est c'est que
les gens viennent pas en campagne pour
vivre au 4e ou au 5e étage donc il leur
faut un petit lopin de terre pour
accueillir de nouveaux habitants sur sa
commune une ZAC une zone d'aménagement
concertée est en cours de construction
avec de futurs logements on a créé une
ZAC nous qui est en partie en
renouvellement urbain puisque 20 % de la
superficie se situ par la destruction
d'une ancienne ferme qui va devenir de
l'habitat mais cette cette ZAC elle a
été faite en plusieurs fois c'est-à-dire
qu'on a trois programmes et le dernier
secteur qui est un secteur sur lequel on
va prendre de la terre agricole si la
loisanne s'applique strict au census on
pourra pas utiliser cette superficie là
10000 nouveaux habitants s'installent
chaque année en î Villaines un enjeu
crucial pour le président de
l'association des MRES ruraux du
département cette loi va accélérer une
tenension sur le logement aujourd'hui on
est en zone tendue puisque moi je vais
prendre l'exemple de ma commune tout
simplement on refuse deux à trois
demandes de location par semaine à la
crise du logement s'ajoute l'objectif de
réindustrialisation comment
réindustrialiser la France et créer de
l'emploi sans consommer de nouvelles
terres c'est la problématique à laquelle
Benoît Cabanis dirigeant de capsock
group tente de répondre dans son usine
de la banlurenaise qui produit des
vérins hydrauliques pour des machines
agricoles la clé de la
réindustrialisation c'est d'avoir des
zones de production d'avoir des zones de
production c'est des mètres carrés alors
après il y a un changement culturel
qu'on doit faire nous les industriels
c'est que pendant très longtemps on se
posait pas trop la question et donc on
travaillait au sol et on noptimisait pas
forcément les mètres cubes de nos usines
je pense que l'avenir il va passer dans
l'optimisation des mètres cubes au lieu
de l'optimisation des mètres carrés
quand on voit nos fournisseurs italiens
ils ont déjà depuis très longtemps dans
le nord de l'Italie des usines à étage
et donc forcément on va tous aller vers
là la France a bétonné autant de terre
en 50 ans qu'au cours des 5 siècles
précédents à partir de demi50 il ne sera
plus possible de consommer le moindre
hectare sans en rendre l'équivalent à la
nature
zan ZFE comment concilier croissance et
urgence environnemental on en débat avec
constance de pelichi bonjour bienvenue
bonjour maire d'ivers droite de la Ferté
saint-auin c'est dans le Loiret et
co-président de la commission
aménagement urbanisme habitat et
logement de de l'AMF Sylvain Laval
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes Le
Maire d'Iv gauche de Saint-Martin de
vinou en iszer co-président de la
commission transport mobilité voirie de
l'Association des MRES de France et puis
vous êtes également vice-président de la
métropole de Grenoble et président du
syndicat mix des mobilités de l'aair
grenobloise on va notamment beaucoup
parler ZFE avec vous mais pas que
Mireille chirole assouine bonjour et
bienvenue économiste spécialiste de
l'environnement et professeur à la Paris
School of Economics et à l'Université
Paris Panthéon Sorbonne Laeticia crupa
est rester à mes côtés évidemment allez
on va on va chapitrer on va commencer
par euh les les anes l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation net puis ensuite on
parlera un peu plus des des et desfeu
zone à faible émission consommer moins
d'espace d'ici moitié moins d'espace
d'ici 2031 et ne plus artificialiser de
nouveaux espaces d'ici
2051 ça c'est l'objectif constance de
pelichi est-ce qu'il est trop ambitieux
est-ce qu'il est tenable tout simplement
bah à l'heure actuelle c'est difficile
de l'imaginer tenable puisque nous
n'avons aucun outil nous permettant de
le tenir le le fond du sujet il est là
outil de quelle N
de nature multiple que ce soit en terme
d'ingénierie en terme de financement ou
autre si on essaie de prendre un petit
peu de hauteur sur le débat qu'est-ce
qu'un maire veut un maire quand il est
élu il veut développer sa commune il
veut avoir une commune dynamique une
commune qui vit l'écrasante majorité des
communes de France sont des communes
rurales dans lesquelles va se poser la
question du maintien de l'école et si
l'école ferme c'est le dernier commerce
qui ferme et si le dernier commerce
ferme
la commune ne vit plus elle meurt pour
éviter ça on va essayer de faire venir
des habitants en particulier des
nouvelles familles pour remplir l'école
de manière à éviter de fermer des
classes et donc derrière d'engendrer une
sorte de spirale infernale et ça c'est
compliqué de le faire tout en respectant
les objectifs zéro artificialisation à
l'heure actuelle dans le monde
périurbain et rural artificialisé
consommer de l'espace coûte 1000 fois
moins cher alors d'un territoire à
l'autre les les ratios sont pas les
mêmes mais coûte infiniment moins cher
que d'aller réhabiliter en
centrebourg donc forcément c'est plus
facile et ça paraît moins cher je dis ça
paraît parce qu'en fait il y a un coût
pour la collectivité au sens large il y
a des problématiques de transport qui
vont se poser derrière il y a des
problématiques de recyclage urbain qui
problématiques de réseau tout ça c'est
la collectivité au sens large qui le
paye mais c'est pas la ménageur et c'est
pas la personne qui va se rendre
propriétaire de son pavillon donc pour
produire du logement pas cher qui
correspond aux besoins ou en tout cas
aux envies des gens bah on a commencé
par produire du pavillon en périphérie
de ville dans le monde périurbain et
rural là où ça permettait aussi de
remplir des écoles oui et on va
évidemment essayer de détailler des des
alternatives ou des ou des solutions
Sylvain Laval les les les conséquences
de cet objectif de de zéro
artificialisation net est-ce que ça se
fait déjà sentir dans votre commune de
Saint-Martin de vinou ou pas
encore pas encore complètement mais bien
sûr on s'interroge on se pose des
questions sur tous les enjeux
d'aménagement à venir que ce soit sur
l'habitat sur les services publics et
aussi sur les enjeux de mobilité puisque
c'est aussi une préoccupation dans ces
dans ces territoires là nous ne savons
pas demain comment nous allons traiter
la question des pistes cyclaabes des
infrastructures de transport collectif
des lignes de bus de tramway puisque ce
sera aussi de l'artificialisation donc
c'est l'ensemble de ces enjeux qui
doivent être pris en compte ce n'est pas
uniquement de l'habitat ou de du
développement économique et c'est à à
long terme voire très long terme c'estàd
c'est pas à la à la comment je peux dire
ça la durée d'un mandat ne suffit pas
pour pour se projeter vers les effets
des décisions que vous êtes amenés à
prendre voyez ce que je veux dire
clairement non puisqu'on est là sur du
moyen et sur du long terme et c'est
précisément notre rôle que de préparer
l'avenir sur sur ces sujets-là et il va
falloir trouver effectivement un
équilibre entre des infrastructures qui
sont collectives qui sont d'intérêt
général qui ont un vrai sujet justement
pour limiter l'étalement urbain et en
même temps le besoin de construire du
logement de développer également de
l'activité oui Mireille chirolo souigne
faut peut-être rappeler en quelques mots
ce dispositif là dont on parle le
l'objectif zan il est échelonné quand
même c'est pas boou d'un seul coup
conformémous à la à la nouvelle règle
oui tout à fait il est il est échelonné
le l'objectif c'est de réduire vous
l'avez dit de moitié l'artificialisation
nette d'ici 2031 donc dans la décennie
2021- 2031 par rapport à la décennie
précédente je me suis amusée d'ailleurs
à regarder sur le site du ministère il y
a un site qui s'appelle on est
aujourd'hui artificialisation non pas où
on en est aujourd'hui mais j'ai regardé
je savais que madame était maire de La
Ferté Saint-Aubin et donc j'ai regardé
la trajectoire entre 2021 et et 2031 qui
serait compatible avec l'objectif étant
donné la trajectoire jusqu'à présent
enfin dans la décennie qui vient de de
s'écouler pour votre commune madame il
faudrait que vous acceptiez donc de
réduire l'artificialisation nette à 2
hactares par an contre 4 hectares par an
en moyenne j'ai vu d'ailleurs sur les
les graphiques qui sont produits par le
sitein je je je vous encourage à aller
les voir si jamais vous ne les
connaissez pas j'ai vu que il y a dû y
avoir un gros projet en 2018 et la
l'artificialisation net a progressé euh
en 2018 fortement euh mais euh depuis la
trajectoire est euh assez euh régulière
et et n'est pas très forte quand on
regarde ce que ça impliquerait pour la
trajectoire prochaine euh c'est Simp
simplement une inflexion la trajectoire
c'estàdire que on moitié moins vous
dites inflexion ça fait beaucoup quand
même oui mais la la la trajectoire
elle-même a eu simplement une pente qui
devient plus faible qui est deux fois
plus faible mais ça n'empêche pas la
croissance ça n n'empêche pas la
croissance et le zéro artificialisation
nette signifie
que toute surface qui est
artificialisée devrait être
compensé pour partie pour respecter cet
objectif par de la renatur
renaturation de d'espace de de sol
autrement dit un retour à la nature ou
une réutilisation d'espace déjà bâti il
ne s'agit pas de cesser de construire
vous le disiez alors je sais pas si je
peux abuser du du temps que vous alle on
on a dans cette émission on a toujours
du temps donc alle d'accord donc vous
disiez que il est 1000 fois moins cher
de construire euh en en augmentant
l'étalement urbain plutôt que de
réhabiliter en centre-ville vous avez
cité les coûts qui pèsent sur la
collectivité en en étalant le l'espace
urbain il y a d'autres coûts qui sont
les externalités environnementales et C
ces coûts c'est tout ce à quoi on
renonce en artificialis en
artificialisant les sols je mentionnerai
peut-être simplement deux effets de
l'artificialisation
elle
empêche le le stockage du carbone dans
les sols naturels or le sol stock du
carbone est encore plus que la forêt que
le le couvert forestier donc ça c'est ça
c'est un et le le deuxème élément et le
deuxème c'est que lorsque les sols sont
artificialisés et
imperméabilisé cela bloque la capacité
d'adaptation des territoires aux
événements climatiques extrêmesment au
inondation notamment aux inondations
votre avis là-dessus consence de de Pich
peut-être sur la trajectoire parce que
c'est intéressant de de de dire est-ce
que vous vous regardez ça de de très
près ou est-ce que bon vous dit de toute
façon l'objectif il est lointin et et il
y a peut-être pas beaucoup de sanctions
donc donc on s'en sortira toujours
comment dans quel état d'esprit vous
êtes l'objectif il est demain donc il
est pas
lointain prendre un exemple simple on
prenait l'exemple de ma commune
justement ou
euh je sais pas ce qui s'est passé en
2018 c'est pourtant pas une année
particulière où on a construit mais ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'il y a eu un
projet de ZAC en pleine extension de la
ville 100 % de l'extension sur sur un
grand nombre d'hectares et bah entre le
moment où on décide de mener une ZAC et
le moment où elle se termine il se passe
pas loin de 15 ans parfois plus en fait
il y a une décorrélation très forte
entre le moment où on pense le projet et
le moment où il se réalise et c'est là
où il y a aussi une très grande crainte
c'est que finalement aujourd aujourd'hui
même si un maire veut réduire fortement
son artificialisation à comptter de
aujourd'hui 21 novembre 2023 bah il y a
plein de coup partis tous les permis
d'aménager tous les permis de construire
qui ont été déposés ce sont des coups
partis je vais prendre un exempleprend
pas coup parti ça veut dire qu je vais
vous donner un exemple très concret sur
ma commune il y a un supermarché qui est
en train de se construire c'est un
permis qui a été déposé en
2017 2017 il n'est toujours pas
construit il va être inauguré là au mois
de mars prochain mais parce que entre le
délai d'instruction qui est parfois
rallongé parce qu'il manque parfois des
pièces plus les recours plus les appels
au recours et cetera on arrive parfois à
des projets urbains qui n'ont plus de
sens par rapport au moment dans lequel
on se trouve alors c'est intéressant ça
rejoint ce que nous dit le président de
l'association écologiste vie et paysage
qui est affilié à France Nature
Environnement on a trop consommé
d'espace Jacques francely le principe
doit être
le principe doit être respecté après il
peut y avoir des des arrangements à la
marge et pas plus parce qu'on on a trop
consommé on est quand même sur un
globalement on est quand même sur sur un
espace la terre elle est finie et on
peut pas avoir une croissance infinie
dans un domaine fini donc toujours plus
toujours plus non je pense pas toujours
plus de terrain toujours plus de
croissance toujours plus non à un moment
il faut faut réfléchir
autrement il faut réfléchir autrement on
a trop consommé Sylvain Laval qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette affirmation et
puis peut-être ça rejoint ce que nous
disait Mireille Chirol àouigne tout à
l'heure sur le le le risque climatique
notamment le risque inondation est-ce
que c'est pas les les cûts seront pas
encore pire si on ne fait rien non mais
c'est évident mais on ne parle pas de
rien non plus ces questions là elles
sont quand même dans l'esprit de
nombreux élus depuis des années nous
avons toujours à l'esprit de limiter
l'étalement la question c'est comment
nous mesurons la limitation de
l'étatemand parce que d'un côté il y a
ces enjeux que nous partageons tous je
crois que sur le principe personne ne
les conteste la question c'est comment
nous les appliquons avec les demandes
que nous avons pour faire face vous le
disiez il y a les questions de risque
naturel il y a des endroitsù aujourd'hui
nous savons qu'il ne faut plus rien ni
faire ne plus rien ni
tenter demand construire du logement on
nous demande d'aménager des services de
mobilité donc il faut trouver c ce que
nous dit jaces franc c'est il faut
réfléchir autrement donc est-ce que ce
ce ce changement de grille d'analyse il
est en cours oui bien sûr nous nous
interrogons sur l'ensemble de nos
politiques publiques pas que sur la
question de la construction c'est
l'objet de ce qu'on appelle les
transitions et nous le faisons sur
l'ensemble de nos champ de politique
publique dans nos collectivités il y a
bien sûr cette réalité climatique qui
évolue et qui nous demande à nous
interroger sur l'ensemble des domaines
sur celui-là comme sur les autres ou mir
chir les solutions c'est quoi on va
parler des friches industrielles qu'on
peut réhabiliter on va parler des des
mètres cubes là c intéressant d'entendre
le le chef d'entreprise tout à l'heure
qui disait il y a des mètres cubes à à
optimiser en quelque sorte là on parle
des des des des usines quelles sont les
solutions principales vous avez cité les
principales mais c'est essentiellement
la densification la densification de
l'habitat comme de des installations
industrielles la réutilisation des
friches industrielles alors évidemment
la dépollution est un grave problème
très souvent sur ces sur ces friches et
donc ça coûte beaucoup plus cher c'est
ce que disait tout à l'heure con de
pelichi ça coûte cher mais c'est
toujours l'arbitrage entre les coûts
privés et les coûts publics le le coût
social est extrêm important si l'on ne
fait pas ça c'est un coout
environnemental qui va être subi par la
biodiversité par exemple je n'en ai pas
parlé tout à l'heure mais qui est
fortement affecté par
l'artificialisation des sols pour
arbitrer est-ce que vous êtes seul ou
est-ce que vous pouvez demander conseil
quand il faut faire un arbitrage al ça
on pose la question à Constance de Pichi
quand on est maire d'une commune comme
La Ferté Saint-Aubin est-ce que vous
avez les expertises c'est un peu la
question de de Laeticia autour de vous
pour pour arbitrer parce que souvent on
est face à des choix qui sont qui sont
compliqués on n'a pas toujours beaucoup
d'expertise et plus on est petit moins
on a d'expertise et ça fait justement
partie des grandes demandes des mères
pour réussir cette transition vers moins
d'artificialisation et même vers une
zéro
artificialisation il faut être
accompagné travailler sur un projet de
requalification de friche c'est un
projet qui est souvent compliqué
travailler sur une autre organisation de
la ville parce que finalement c'est
cette question-là qui est posée par
Lausanne comment on arrive à être
dynamique autrement bah il faut être
accompagné et peu de communes le sont en
particulier lorsqu'elles ont euh une
taille beaucoup plus modeste h euh je
vous propose un autre témoignage sur
toujours sur ce cette question de de
l'artificialisation euh et je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant c'est le maire de
châautiri Sébastien Eugène il dit
attention ça risque de figer les
inégalités entre communes écoutons et
donc ça fige les inégalités les
territoires qui sont beaucoup développés
vont pouvoir se développer les
territoires qui malheureusement ont pu
connaître même le un déclin
démographique ou économique et ben elle
on va figer ce ce déclin et ça pose une
vraie difficulté châteautiierri est un
bon exemple pendant nombreuses années
nous avons eu une décroissance
démographique et au moment où il y a une
forte demande sur la commune et bien on
est pénalisé par l'existence de ces
quotas ouis effectivement si je détaille
un peu plus chateau tiri avait décliné
quand même beaucoup à la fin des années
90 fermeture d'usine en cascade et
aujourd'hui il y a de nouveau un
développement 1000 habitants
supplémentaires euh ces 5 dernières
années fort développement économique on
est au cœur de notre débat Mirol souigne
est-ce qu'on peut concilier croissance
pour les communes et on c'est vrai que
l'objectif d'un mer ça peut être de de
de rester ou de d'être de plus en plus
attirant pour des des nouveaux des
nouveaux administrés donc croissance de
la commune et urgence écologique est-ce
que c'est conciliable c'est toujours le
problème de la compatibilité entre la
croissance et l'urgence écologique il y
a il y a de vrais arbitrages à opérer
maintenant il faut pas oublier non plus
que la population française connaît une
croissance qui n'est pas aussi forte que
que celle qui a pu être expérimentée
dans les décennies précédentes par
conséquent s'il y a des communes qui
croissent c'est sans doute qu'il y en a
qui décroissent et donc oui mais si ça
bloque une commune finalement dans un un
stade de de développement parce
qu'effectivement elle a eu le la
malchance de voir des usines fermé il y
a il y a il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans bon ben
on lui dit ah benah non zéro
artificialisation net vous enz là alors
l'objectif de zéro artificialisation
nette c'est un objectif de long terme et
un objectif national oui maintenant la
déclinaison au niveau municipal au
niveau des communes au niveau des
collectivités pourrait très certainement
être
flexibilisé jusqu'à présent ça n'a pas
l'air d'avoir d'être véritablement le
cas mais on pourrait imaginer que ça
soit plus flexible que que ce soit au
sein d'une collectivité de d'une d'une
région ou au sein d'un département que
l'objectif de zéro artificialisation
nette soit
réalisé l'économiste que je suis quand
quand elle entend parler de quota pense
aussitôt quota négociable pourquoi n'y
aurait-il pas des échanges de quotas
entre des zones qui souhaitent se
développer qui ont de véritables
opportunités à se développer et des
zones qui pour lesquelles c'est moins
nécessaire ou pour lesquels il est plus
facile de requalifier des des espac à ma
connaissance non là ne sont pas
négociables en pour l'instant ce ce
casse-tête dont on parle ici sur ce
plateau il est au cœur des enjeux de ce
105e congrès des des maires de France on
est juste à côté du Grand Auditorium
voilà il y a les conférences qui s
déroulent les élus qui qui entent qui
sortent et qui passent derrière nous on
va parler évidemment parce que ça se
rejoint avec ce que vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure des catastrophes
climatiques des catastrophes naturelles
dans ce débat pour ouvrir ce chapitre je
vous propose des écouter le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron c'était
lors de son déplacement dans le Pas de
Calais ce sur quoi nous avons basé
l'organisation de nos paysage nos
organisations productives ce pourquoi on
vous parle temps d'artificialisation des
sols en disant qu'il faut aussi des
mécanismes pour pas tellement
artificialiser c'est jamais populaire
quand on le dit parant de paix on voit
ce que ça donne quand vous avez beaucoup
d'artificialisation l'eau ruelle sur les
mêmes endroits elle vient s'accumuler ça
vous montre la la nécessité de ces
politiques et évidemment les mécanismes
d'accompagnement financier doivent être
doit doiv évoluer on l'a fait pour le
monde agricole en mobilisant à la fois
du public du privé on devra le faire sur
les grands risques et ça c'est une
discussion à voir avec les assureurs et
les réassureurs les assurances justement
Laeticia c'est le thème de votre
chronique ça a fait l'objet d'une étude
récente dites-nous tout oui c'est une
étude sur les mes face au dérèglement
climatiques he effectué par le cabinet
de conseil de Bossom project pour la
tribune l'étude a été dévoilée dimanche
dans la tribune dimanche et elle analyse
le goulot d'étranglement dans lequel
beaucoup de maires de communes sinistré
se retrouvent pourquoi parce que Thomas
ils sont tout simplement lâché par leur
assureurs qui dans C ce contexte
difficile de de multirise ont soit
carrément dénoncer leur contrat on dit
on se retire on ne peut plus vous
assurer ou alors ont décidé de réévaluer
les franchises et alors là parfois ça
fait très mal certaines communes ont vu
leur franchise passer de 1500 € à 2
millions donc il faut pouvoir suivre et
l'étude montre on l'a dit sur ce plateau
he que les maires face aux défis
écologique sont obligés de se projeter
bien plus loin que la durée de leur
mandat alors que souvent les habitants
eux sont ont les yeux rivés sur leurs
intérêts immédiats et donc l'étude
conclut qu'il faut absolument que le
secteur privé l'assureur
entre dans le jeu et aide les maires
pour participer et réaliser les travaux
demandés ce qui pour l'instant est loin
d'être le cas est-ce que l'État pourrait
venir à la rescous c'est en tout cas ce
que certains éil demandent puisque hier
pas plus tard qu'hier un collectif a
publié une tribune dans le monde je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez vu le journal Le
Monde avec un titre très clair face au
désengagement des assureurs nous maire
des petites villes de France appel don
le gouvernement a réagir donc ça fera
peut-être l'objet alors ça c'est un
petit off comme on dit ou c'est-à-dire
que j'ai laissé traîner mon oreille et
du côté de l'Élysée on m'a dit
qu'Emmanuel Macron pourrait aborder le
sujet demain soir avec les maires qui le
reçoit à l'Élysée et annoncer certains
aménagements sur cette question des
assurances on est bien d'accord cette
question des assurance mais
officiellement on sait déjà quelque
chose est fait du côté de l'État un
rapport a été commandé euh par
l'exécutif sur la mise en place
d'assureurs spécifiques pour les
collectivités territoriales et là cela
pourrait permettre un changement de
paradigme Thomas si les acteurs privés
prenaient leur part finalement dans
toutes les adaptations écologiques hein
qui sont demandé aux municipalités à
commencer pourquoi pas vous en avez
touché deux mots mais par les démarches
administratives qui sont parfois
totalement énergivore et dans laquelle
les maires peuvent se perdre donc on
attend bien sûr évidemment de voir c'est
le plus important quelle participation
financière pourront prendre les acteurs
privés pour soulager les municipalité et
donc ce rapport on commandé par
l'exécutif les conclusions elles sont
attendues pour quand en avril mois av
d'avril donc avec le temps de la mise en
œuvre il faudra certainement attendre la
rentrée septembre 2024 pour commencer à
avoir un éventuel changement et surtout
un appel d'air pour les maires alors vos
retours de témoignage l'un et l'autre
Sylvain Laval pour commencer est-ce que
vous connaissez aujourd'hui des
difficultés pour assurer votre commune
ou peut-être si on voit plus large
l'intercommunalité s'il y en a alors ma
commune non parce que justement nous
sommes dans une grande intercommunalité
urbaine et donc nous avons la capacité à
travailler en commun de bénéficier de
regroupement ce qu'on appelle des
groupement de commande il est évident
que nous connaissons de nombreux
collègues qui à l'échelle de communes
beaucoup plus petites dans des
intercommunalités moins denses font face
à ces difficultés qui sont une vraie
réalité aujourd'hui oui et votre retour
d'expérience constance de Pichi assuré
pas assuré la commune pourstant assuré
euh avec une réelle difficulté sur
certains équipements publics notamment à
la suite de catastrophes climatique euh
nous avons eu la la désagréable surprise
de noyer notre piscine lors d'inondation
en 2016 et l'assureur c'est c'est
désengagé hein il n'a pas souhaité
renouveler le contrat euh avec quel
motif bah ça coûtait trop cher tout
simplement enfin ils cherchent pas à
s'embarrasser de beaucoup de motifs hein
euh ils arrivent à c'est des contrats
d'un an en général renouvelables deux ou
trois fois par tacite reconduction et à
l'échéance d'un an ça arrive très
fréquemment que la prime explose sans
réel motif d'ailleurs ou que l'assureur
résilie du jour au lendemain de vra
question on poser des questions ultra
concrètes ça veut dire que la piscine de
la ville elle n'est plus assurée
aujourd'hui ou alors ça coûouvé un autre
assureur mais globalement les
équipements il y a il y a énormément
d'équipements publics qui ne sont pas
assurés ou très faiblement assuré y
compris là aujourd'hui on parle des
mairies mais à l'échelle d'une région ou
d'un département qu'en est-il des
collèges des lycées qui sont également
faiblement assurés qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de l'État même question pour
l'un et l'autre pour commencer Sylvain
Laval puisque il y a effectivement nous
en parlait cette rencontre à l'Élysée
demain moi j'attends de l'État qu'il
nous aide à alléger et simplifier les
procédure c'est un vrai mal français
alors qu'il n'est pas nouveau on en
parle beaucoup mais on agit quand même
peu sur sur cette question et on voit
bien aujourd'hui que quand on veut
avancer sur un certain nombre de projets
c'est des années des années de
procédures préalables avant même
d'engager des recherches de financement
ou de lancer des travaux et face à nous
nous avons des attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens qui demandent justement
d'engager ces transition d'avoir des
services adaptés aux enjeux de demain et
pour sortir un certain nombre de projets
on voit que nous sommes aujourd'hui
englués dans une complexité
administrative qui ne fait que retarder
les choses donc on a vraiment besoin
d'alléger pour raccourcir les délais
ouais constance de Pichi même même
question de demain soir à l'Élysée je
sais pas si vous y allez l'
personnellement je je n'ai pas la
possibilité de laal vous y allez ou pas
allez àéée demain soir ou vous y serez
ben vous pourrez faire passer le message
sur cette question des
assurancesia peut-être des annonces
présidentielles des aménagements
qu'est-ce que vous en espérez bah que
chaque collectivité qui le souhaite
puisse être assuré enfin c'est déjà un
élément fondamental et être assuré dans
des conditions raisonnables c'est-à-dire
avec une prime d'assurance cohérente au
regard du bien qui est assuré et des
franchises qui sont également cohérentes
au regard du bien assuré si on regarde
les communes qui ont subi des
catastrophes climatiques euh dans le
nord de la France ces dernières semaines
comment vont-elles si elles ne sont pas
correctement assurées pouvoir rouvrir
leurs écoles h rouvrir les équipements
publics de première nécessité quand ils
ont connu 50 cm d'eau 1 m d'eau c'est
impossible on n'a pas 1 million 2
millions 3 millions d'euros à mettre sur
la table en urgence on les pas tout
simplement Mireille chir souligne quelle
forme ça pourrait prendre là ce ce
système d'assurance spécifique pour les
les les communes pour les
intercommunalités là vous vous me vous
me parce que alors je vais vous poser
une autre question qui est presque plus
général c'est la la question du modèle
économique des assurances c'est ça qui
est en train de se poser pas seulement
pour les les les infrastructur communal
d'ailleurs les compagnies d'assurance
privée mutualisent le risque
c'est-à-dire qu'elles assurent de très
nombreux risques en sachant que elles
n'auront à indemniser des sinistres que
dans une proportion très faible qu'elles
savent calculer et qu'elles savent de
moins en moins calculer avec le
changement climatique et ces événements
clim plus en plus de catastrophes ou
d'événement extr absolument et donc
cette mutualisation les amène à calculer
des primes qu'ell demande aux différents
assurés de façon à équilibré tout en
retirant un profit ce sont des
compagnies privées et donc je pense que
l'une des l'une des voix serait très
certainement
une la création de systèm d'assurance
qui soit des des des mutuels des
coopérative qui n'est pas d'objectif de
profit fondamentalement afin de pouvoir
couvrir l'ensemble des risques à des
taux raisonnables mais attention la
Fédération Française de l'assurance a
mis en garde récemment pour dire que un
réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés Est
assurable un réchauffement climatique
pour la France à 4 degrés n'est plus
assurable et ça c'est c'est vrai pour
les collectivités mais c'est vrai pour
l'ensemble des des des individus qui
souhaitent s'assurer et donc il y a un
vrai problème de l'assurance qui est
plus large que celui que rencontrent les
collectivités actuellement voilà et ça
fait partie des informations de ces
dernières semaines on est déjà à plus de
degrés on l'a passé plusieurs fois et
donc l'objectif des 1 et demi qui était
l'objectif des accords de Paris on sait
déjà que on n'y arrivera pas donc là
vraiment ça va être compliqué de de ne
pas passer à de 2 et demi ou TR ou 3
degrés on a beaucoup parlé là de euh de
de logement d'artificialisation des sols
on va consacrer la dernière partie de ce
débat euh et vous avez dit vous nous
l'avez dit c'est lié aux questions de de
mobilité ZFE un autre acronyme pour zone
à faible émission des grandes villes de
plus de 150000 habitants qui interdisent
l'accès au véhicules trop polluant ça
c'est ce qui est en perspective on va
dire ça comme ça dispositif qui suscite
là aussi l'inquiétude de de nombreux
élus je vous propose d'entendre madame
le Maire de lingolshim on est dans le
barrain on est à une quinzaine de
kilomètres de Strasbourg c'est
évidemment l'une des capitales régional
qui a instauré une ZnFe moi j'ai reçu en
mairie beaucoup de personnes très
inquiètes et notamment des retraités
parce que quand vous avez 75 ans que
vous pensez que c'est votre dernière
voiture que vous roulez très peu vous
allez faire quelques cours alleer voir
en weekend de vos enfants vous allez
faire peu de kilomètres ils ne peuvent
pas comprendre qu'il doit
changer leur voiture et ils ne l'ont pas
prévu dans leur budget donc moi je pense
qu'il y avait vraiment une réflexion
beaucoup plus grande à faire sur les
dérogation on peut pas mettre au même
niveau quelqu'un qui utilise de façon
épisodique sa voiture et quelqu'un qui
roule régulièrement voilà ces enjeux de
de mobilité au cœur évidemment des
préoccupations des élus des des maires
qui sont ici réunis au au Salon des
Maires Porte de Versailles à à Paris
105e congrès des maires de France
Sylvain Laval le le dispositif initial
des des ZF je crois que c'est ça ça
prévoyait 45 ZFE à l'horizon 2025 les
villes de plus de 150000 habitants
est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité ça
tiens ou est-ce que c'est pas en train
d'être lentement mais sûrement abandonné
alors ça c'est ce que posait la loi
climat et résilience effectivement et
c'est un objectif qui est toujours
valable sur le plan légal après nous
avons eu depuis peu des précision de la
part du gouvernement sur cette question
qui nous dit que l'instauration de ces
ZFE peut-être plus pr
dans les territoires qui ne sont pas en
dépassement des normes nationales sur la
qualité de l'air et donc évidemment ça
vous donne une lecture différencié en
fonction des territoires dans lesquels
vous vous trouvez donc ça veut dire que
si on prend l'exemple des des grandes
agglomérations qui ont déjà adopté des
des a feux est-ce qu'elles sont bien
audessus des des normes
environnementales dont vous nous parlez
des normes de pollution ou est-ce que
finalement elles pourrai même renoncer à
leur ZFE alors non les textes ne disent
pas qu'on peut renoncer à la ZFE les
textes disent qu'on peut y aller plus pr
progressivement mais ça ne remet pas en
cause le principe d'application et de
création des ZFE la plupart des grandes
villes qui sont d'ors et déjà en ZFE ont
nécessité au regard des critères légaux
d'appliquer ces ZFE et d'autres ont
choisi leur rythme d'y aller de débuter
et elles auront le loisir de définir le
rythme de développement et
d'accélération ouais je discutais
récemment avec le député des Yvelines
Bruno milen qui est un des grands
spécialistes de ces de ces questions qui
lui doute de l'extension du dispositif à
toutes les villes depuis 0000 habitants
mire Chirol àouig c'est vrai qu'elles
sont en train de cristalliser quand même
beaucoup d'opposition c'est ces AFE
est-ce qu'on pourra s'en passer pour
autant si on veut tenir les objectifs
dont on parlait tout à l'heure les afux
sont pensés pour réduire la pollution
dans les villes la pollution due à la
circulation il est patant que la France
ne respecte pas les normes qui sont
fixées au niveau européen et qui sont
fix F à un niveau qui n'est pas très
exigeant c'estàd elle a déjà été
condamnée pour ça d'ailleurs elle elle a
été condamnée déjà à plusieurs reprises
à payer une astreinte à l'association à
l'ONG les Amis de la Terre qui a attaqué
devant le Conseil d'État et elle va
vraisemblablement être condamné une
nouvelle fois à payer une nouvelle
astreinte puisque le rapporteur devant
le Conseil d'État le 8 novembre dernier
a préconiser de nouveau de faire payer
l'astreinte parce que il y a toujours
des des dépassements c'est des feux là
aussi ce sont des zones à faible
émission mais il y a une certaine
flexibilité non seulement dans le
calendrier de mise en place mais dans la
façon dont ces zones peuvent être mises
en place et en particulier il est
possible d'accorder des dérogations pour
certaines pour certaines raisons il est
possible de limiter le nombre de jours
de circulation par par véhicule mais
sans que ce soit pour autant uniforme il
il y a la possibilité d'adapter les
choses et il y a en particulier la
possibilité de relâcher la contrainte
sur la circulation à partir du moment où
les normes ne seraiit plus dépassé mais
c'est il faut que cet objectif soit
réalisé parce que c'est un enjeu de
santé publique en fait la popul la
pollution constance de pelichi est-ce
que c'est est-ce qu'on vous en parle
souvent tiens et et question subsidiaire
qui qui peut sembler totalement
anecdotique mais k est-ce que vous voyez
rouler beaucoup de vour électriques dans
dans votre commune ou ou autour de la
commune alors très honnêtement on ne
m'en parle jamais d'accord intéressant
et pourtant nous sommes dans l'aire
urbaine d'Orléan qui du coup entre sous
le coup de cette question des
AFE nous avons la chance d'avoir une
gare qui nous permet d'être dans le
centre-ville d'Orléan plus rapidement
que si on y va en voiture donc là-dessus
c'est une chance inestimable mais revers
de la médaille nous sommes situé sur la
fameuse ligne POLT Paris Orléan limoche
Toulouse qui est la ligne à priori l'une
des lignes les plus catastrophiques de
France en terme d'entretien donc et en
terme de retard aussi en terme de train
supprimés de train retardés et cetera il
y a pas une semaine sans qu'il y ait
plusieurs incidents sur les créneaux
horaires les plus important donc c'est
un site à prendre sa voiture é c'est
site à prendre sa voiture nous faisons
partie nous dans le Loiré d'une des
premières communautés de communes en
dehors des grosses agglomérations on est
une communauté de communes rurales à
avoir développé sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire des bonnes des bornes de
recharge pour les véhicules électriques
elle remporte du succès donc y compris
dans les territoires ruraux il y a du
succès au départ on l'avait fait pour
les véhicules en transit parce qu'on est
sur la route des vacances mais on se
rend compte que ça bénéficie également
aux résidents dont on pensait qu'ils
allaient plutôt se garer chez eux vous
avez dû l'expliquer ou pas du tout à vos
administr comment ça marche non Glob en
fait les gens qui ont déjà acquis un
véhicule électrique globalement R très
vite dans le système donc on a plutôt
des bons retours pour l'instant comme
elles sont neuves la maintenance se fait
assez facilement je sais pas combien de
temps ça va durer mais petit à petit
effectivement on commence à avir des
véhicules électriques y compris dans le
monde rural mais ça reste assez poussif
pour l'instant Sylvain Laval comment
dissuader les habitants des zones
rurales de prendre leur voiture parce
que c'est ça vraiment la la question
plein de leviers possibles à à activer
qu'est-ce qui vous semble vous le plus
plus intéressant ou peut-être le plus
efficace alors c'est tout l'enjeu de
cesones aff mission c'est de ne pas
opposer les habitants les uns aux autres
et surtout les territoires les uns les
autres et de ne pas créer une fracture
entre les territoires périphériques
ruraux et les centres urbain si on
habite dans ces territoires c'est parce
que on les aime aussi ou parce que
parfois c'est plus facile de s'y loger
parce que c'est moins cher il faut aussi
prendre en compte cette réalitélà donc
vous ne pouvez pas dire à ces gens-là
bah écoutez débrouillez-vous laissez
votre voiture et puis c'est comme ça
pour que ça fonctionne il faut qu'il y
ait une offre en face il a une réponse
une alternative sérieuse ma collègue
citait évidemment le ferroviaire qui est
le plus intéressant mais quand on a des
lignes quand on a des lignes qui
fonctionnent quand on a des gares
adaptées donc ça veut dire qu'il nous
faut mettre en face des offres de
mobilité nouvelles ça peut-être du bus
ça peut être des pôles d'échange
multimodau on va pouvoir venir se garer
se rabattre sur des services de mobilité
ou développer d'autres services comme le
vélo mais tout ça ça demande des
aménagement ça demande du coût et donc
on a des contraintes qui peuvent
s'appliquer très rapidement et en face
un temps d'adaptation pour amener les
infrastructures de réponses qui vont
être beaucoup plus longues et les moyens
financiers parce que c'est une vraie
question est-ce que est-ce que ça veut
dire que qui son beaucoup plus général
qui va au-delà d'ailleurs des des des
ZFE mais est-ce qu'il faudrait créer une
sorte de dette verte vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est permettre aux
communes de s'endetter spécifiquement
pour pour répondre à ces à ces enjeux de
de d'urgence climatique ce qui est
certain c'est que les collectivités
auront bien sûr un un rôle important à
jouer en la matière et elles le font
mais elles ne pourront pas le faire seul
c'est un travail collectif partenarial
de l'ensemble des des niveaux de
collectivité territoriale mais aussi de
l'état puisque ça a été dit on s'inscrit
dans un cadre national voire même
européen la question elle se pose pose
partout à l'échelle du territoire et
donc il va falloir aussi adapter nos
outils nationaux pour pousser ce
développement et cette accélération des
réponse de mobilité que nos citoyens
nous demandent immédiatement et qui
prennent malheureusement encore beaucoup
trops concrement qu'est-ce que vous avez
mis en place alors nous on a mis en dans
votre commune soit plus génalchelle des
intercommunalités parce qu'on peut
difficilement gérer ça à une seule
échelle communale donc nous mettons en
place bah le développement des service
de mobilité que j'évoqué sur les
transports en commun sur le vélo sur un
ensemble de combinaisons servic pour
accpagner parce que l'enje des a c'est
que ce ne soit pas un dispositif
d'exclusion sociale et donc nous ciblons
des aides en ce qui concerne notre
territoire sur le métropole de Grenoble
sur des publics les plus fragiles pour
les aider à consommer des services de
mobilité pour les aider à acheter un
certain nombre de véhicules nouveaux que
ce soit des vélos parfois même des
véhicules en ultime recours routier mais
l'idée c'est vraiment de les faire
basculer sur de nouveaux services de
mobilité en les aidant y compris sur le
plan
financier je parlais de det verte est-ce
que c'est à l'étude est-ce que c'est une
idée ça c'est c'est une possibilité
maintenant euh le les les établissements
de crédit accorderont-ils des des
crédits spécifique à des taux qui ne
soient pas plus élevés que euh pour pour
d'autres dépenses là aussi ce serait
quelque chose à mettre en place de de de
façon centralisée ou parce que l'État
français est très endetté est-ce que les
communes le sont euh tout autant ah ben
les communes le sont alors après c'est
inégalement réparti mais mais mais les
communes le sont le sont beaucoup euh on
on pourrait penser aussi à une
répartition régionale de certaines
recettes fiscales et en particulier là
où on a eu une opposition très forte à
le l'augmentation du taux de la taxe
carbone on pourrait peut-être combiner
euh une augmentation de ce taux avec une
redistribution du rendement à un niveau
régional ou un niveau départementale en
en rapprochant en quelque sorte de la
population et de la prise de décision
euh publi mais plus plus local c'est ces
décisions au sujet de la fisc de la
fiscalité écologique qui redeviendra
enfin qui est indispensable et qui
reviendra à l'ordre du jour à un moment
oui dans les initiatives possible il y a
aussi le peut-être que vous l'avez fait
ou que vous ça existe dans vos régions
respectives mais des des lignes de de
covoiturage d'autopartage qui
fonctionnent comme des lignes de
d'autobus avec des arrêts qui sont
définis et des applications et on vous
garantit
le passage d'une d'une voiture toutes
les 3 ou 5 minutes c'est assez c'est
assez étonnant intéressant constance de
de pelichi c'est quoi le le bon niveau
administratif pour vous pour prendre les
les les décisions justement en matière
de mobilité c'est quoi
l'intercommunalité à à minima c'est le
département c'est la région tous les
territoires ne se ressemblent pas c'est
vrai donc c'est difficile de répondre
avec une seule réponse à votre question
on a des communautés de communes qui
comptent 50 so 70 communes qui sont sur
un bassin métropolitain moi je suis sur
une communauté de communes qui compte 7
communes
rurale forcément la question de la
mobilité va pas se poser du tout de la
même manière l'échelle pertinente ce
serait malgré tout de travailler à
l'échelle d'un bassin de vie
c'est-à-dire de regarder quels sont les
les déplacements les plus fréquents des
gens pour aller travailler he les plus
gros des déplacements c'est quand même
le domicile travail pour apporter un
premier niveau de
mais vous parliez tout à l'heure du
financement et de la dette verte oui il
y a l'investissement mais ce qui nous
fait parfois reculer c'est qu'il faut
les faire fonctionner derrière si il ne
s'agit pas simplement d'aller investir
dans les rails et la locomotive il ne
dans votre piste cyclable mais lorsque
vous allez développer un réseau de
transport en commun en souvent du
transport à la demande dans le monde
rural faut payer les chauffeurs vous le
faites comment c'est pas une dette
écologique qui va les payer merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce à
ce débat et à ce sens public spécial
congrès des maires de France d'autres
émissions de la chaîne évidemment vous
seront proposés depuis ce studio au cœur
du Salon des mères merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité à Sens public
notez que demain l'invité de la la
matinale Dorian mansini ce sera
Jean-François Copé le maire de ma belle
soirée
[Musique]